joe biden was having the time of his
life man
things were just going fantastically now
that doesn't mean that joe biden said
many coherent things
in fact joe biden said many things that
were um quite bizarre and some of them
were
quite radical he changed his positions
on some pretty core
issues so let's start with the bizarre
and the and the radical
so joe biden was specifically asked
about police action he has said this
stupid thing in the past and he said it
again last night
he suggested that we need to train the
police to shoot people in the leg
this is a talking point by morons this
is a talking point for people who don't
know anything about policing and don't
know anything about guns
this is not gene wilder in blazing
saddles guys
i mean first honestly if we're gonna do
this then really they shouldn't even
shoot the attacker in the leg what they
should do is shoot the
the gun or weapon out of an attacker's
hand
right that's really they should shoot
the trigger finger they should make it
so that you can't pull the trigger
finger like in the movies
this is what joe biden actually thinks
okay so the way that law enforcement
actually works
is that in the heat of the moment when
you have a just a split second
to react many of the shots go wild this
is why you are taught to fire until the
threat is neutralized
you're taught to fire at center of body
mass specifically because very often you
cannot aim
at a particular part of the body this
comes from somebody who obviously has
never really tried handling a handgun
and certainly not in a pressure
situation this idiotic notion
you can train police to shoot at limbs
is the stupidest garbage ever put forth
by people who talk about guns so here's
joe biden he's done this multiple times
and it's amazing no one asks
where's the follow-up from george
stephanopoulos why is it that not a
single police department in america
trains people to shoot at limbs
because you cannot do that it does not
work here is joe biden laying this
fourth because he's an idiot
there's a lot of things we've learned
and it takes time but we can do this you
can ban
choke holes you can but but beyond that
you have to
teach people how to de-escalate
circumstances
de-escalate so instead of anybody coming
at you the first thing you do is shoot
to kill
you shoot them in the leg shoot them in
the leg
shoot them in the leg that's the instead
of shooting your kill shoot them in like
uh-huh
that's that's amazing i don't understand
why doesn't why don't the cops take out
a lightsaber
and just like you know melt the bullets
that are being shot at them
and then go over and disarm the person
by like cutting off their arm like luke
skywalker
does or like like obi-wan kenobi or
something
in fact why doesn't why don't the cops
just use wonder woman's lasso of truth
and actually just like
this is a presidential candidate who's
supposed to be your serious presidential
candidate speaking of serious
presidential candidates
joe biden was asked once again on court
packing once again he declined to answer
joe he was not pressed by george
stephanopoulos he said don't worry i'll
tell you at some point
at some point you'll find out i mean
that point may never come
but sometime in the future i mean the
future is full of murkiness and
undecidedness so
at some point i'll probably tell you
here's joe biden not being asked a
difficult question
if they vote on it before the election
if they vote out before the election
you are open to expanding the court i'm
open to
considering what happens from that point
on
you know you said so many times during
the campaign all through the course of
your career it's important to level
it is but george if i if i say no matter
what answer i gave you
if i say it that's the headline tomorrow
it won't be about what's going on now
the improper way they're proceeding but
don't voters have a right to know where
they do have a right to know that i
stand and i'll have a right to know
where i stand before they vote
so you'll come out with a clear position
before election day yes depending on how
they handle this
depending on how they handle this i love
that okay so what should george
stephanopoulos's answer there be
clearly if you were a journalist or if
you were going to savannah guthrie this
thing he would say okay why not right
now
like i'm looking at my watch here joe
and it turns out that today is
in fact october 15th and the election is
going to be held
in approximately two and a half weeks so
you're running out of time so why not do
it like right now
what's preventing you from doing it like
right now and instead your baby's like
well you know i'm just not gonna tell
you
everything's good and george stephen's
like okay joe all right well fair enough
not fair enough oh man okay
george stephanopoulos that's some harsh
questioning right there it shows you
the media standard for themself the
media's standard is that if you are
interviewing a republican you should act
like savannah guthrie and if you are if
you're interviewing joe biden you should
act like a doormat
that is the media double standard and
again that doesn't alleviate the fact
that trump handled some questions
badly last night and then he tweets dumb
crap these are separate issues
the media bias is very real there's a
reason conservatives distrust the media
there's a reason they distrust social
media they continue to promote
mainstream media
okay but back to biden so biden said
many many radical things last night
he said yesterday that small children
should be able to transition i know that
we're just going to gloss over this
thing
but this is insane this is insane so a
mother of a child
who believes that he is transgender an
eight-year-old eight
years old gets up and says you know joe
what are you gonna do for kids like mine
a boy who believes he's a girl who
believes he is transgender and joe biden
says we should allow eight-year-olds and
ten-year-olds to transition
those are children so he's talking about
right now
is allowing the treatment of a boy
as a girl not watchful waiting but an
eight-year-old says i think i'm a girl
today and that
kid is a boy and you say okay darling
and then you go out and buy
and you call them your daughter you
literally start treating the boy is a
girl
okay this is not best medical practice
there is not evidence to back that this
is a good idea
but this is the left propaganda which is
that you can identify
as a member of the opposite sex right
you can you can just pick your opposite
six at the age of eight
at the age of eight here's joe biden
spilling this one out there and he's
going to effectuate federal policy in
order to make this clear
so if you are a religious school for
example then he is going to make it so
that if a little boy
comes in and he now wants to identify as
a little girl and he wants to go to the
girls school
right because in a lot of religious
communities you have a separate boy
school and a separate girls school
mainly because once they hit teenage
years you want to keep those kids
separated
okay but they have separate boys schools
and separate girls schools this is very
traditional in the religious community
it's very traditional in the jewish
community catholic community
evangelical protestant community that
joe biden will be the kind of person who
believes that you should be able to take
your boy and
enlist that kid in the girls school and
the school should simply deal with it
not only that he believe i mean on a
fundamental level believing that an
eight-year-old should be able to
transition his madness it's absolute
madness
i wouldn't let my i have a six-year-old
i would not let her choose
how to cut her own hair let alone how to
shape her own sexual future that's
insane
and the uh it's it's crazy it's one
thing you're talking about a 20 year old
it's an it's another thing i mean
there are their problems too but if
you're 20 at least you have the ability
to think things through and consent if
you're eight you don't
but here's joe biden yesterday basically
standing up for the ability of eight
year olds to transition
the idea that an eight-year-old child or
a ten-year-old child decides
you know i decided i want to be
transgender that's what i think i'd like
to be
make my life a lot easier there should
be zero discrimination there is no
reason to suggest that there should be
any
right denied your daughter or daughters
whichever
one or two one one your daughter that
your other daughter has a right to be
and do
none zero okay it's not discrimination
to deny a boy access to a girl's locker
room
it is not discrimination to deny a boy
eight years old the ability to
hormonally transition
the hell is he talking about that is
radical stuff i know that the media
portrays this as mainstream
that is deeply radical and not only that
it will reach the
point in american politics in very very
short order because you're already
seeing the early indicators
where if you as a parent say no to this
the government will
intervene and joe biden will back that
if you have an eight-year-old and your
eight-year-old goes to school your
eight-year-old boy goes to school
and he says to the teacher i feel like a
girl today and then the next day
your eight-year-old boy goes to school
he tells the teacher you know i went
home i told mommy i feel like a girl
and mommy said you're not a girl you're
a boy the teacher calls child protective
services
okay we are this far from that you watch
within the next five years this will
become
rote okay that is something that that
is incredibly dangerous to children it's
incredibly dangerous to families
it's incredibly dangerous to basic human
reason what joe biden said there is
radical it is radical and it is to say
an eight-year-old should be able to
transition
is is pretty horrifying on every
possible level okay but it's treated as
totally not only normal but sympathetic
and good
because eight-year-olds should be able
to make their own decisions on
everything including what sex they are
in contravention of reality all right
that is your moderate that is your
moderate candidate joe biden
if you enjoyed this video be sure to hit
the thumbs up button and share it with
all of your friends